quand même très étonnant on va passer à
une autre info qui est tombé aujourd'hui
je sais pas si vous avez vu cette info
500 smartphones ont été offerts au
migrants à calier dans le cadre de
l'opération smartphone suspendu lancé
par les Ateliers du Bocage une
association lié à emus bonne ou mauvaise
initiative regardez cet extrait mardi 9
association calaisienne ont réceptionné
500 smartphones des dons de la part
d'emus Connect faciliter les échanges
entre les associations et les personnes
exilées c'est l'objectif pour chaque
téléphone acheté cetteop en offre à une
de ses associations humanitaires on
essaie d'en vendre le maximum pour
pouvoir donner une seconde vie à ces
téléphonees et aussi en faire bénéficier
un maximum de de personnes rupture
numérique d'ici quelques jours les
associations bénéficiaires distribueront
les smartphones reçus aux migrants alors
il y a des gens qui voilà qui qui ont
réagi là-dessus voilà vous vous trouvez
vous trouvez que c'est une bonne
initiative moi je trouve ça formidable
c'est un peu comme le café suspendu vous
allez dans un bar vous payez un café
pour une personne qui viendra qui n'a
pas les moyens et ben là c'est c'est
avec le téléphone et en plus ces
migrants comme ça ils seront en lien
avec des associations ils ne seront pas
perdus il y aura un contact donc je
trouve l'initiative formidable NOTAM je
comprends pas très bien parce qu'on leur
donne un téléphone jusqu'àpr du
contraire faut un abonnement faut un
opérateur pour PIR tééphoner donc je
vois pas très bien j'ai cru j'ai cru
comprendre que était dans le plus grand
dénuement alors est-ce qu'ils vont payer
un abonnement SFR bi et cetera pour
appeler le leur famille et cetera je
comprends très bien le concept là si
c'est un téléphone qui sert à rien c'est
des mag ou donc c'est quoi c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est la démagogie c'est
quoi ch est-ce que vous avez les infos
parce que c'est vrai qu'il a raison il
faut fa un abonnement non il il serend
lien en tout cas je ce sera pas fait
pour appeler l'étranger puisque ce sera
fait pour établir le lien avec un
abonnement Mme pour pas appeler
l'étranger tu Besin d'abonnement c'est
complètement des Mago on sait que ces
gens-l ils sont dans une énorme misère a
priori malheureusement leur parcours il
est dessiné être chaotique et là pour se
donner une bonne conscience on va leur
offrir un smartphone encore une fois qui
paye l'abonnement pour faire quoi
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire avec ils
vont pas jouer à Candy crush alors que
les pauvr ils vont peut-être être
envoyés dans leur pays non mais c'est
n'importe quoi vrai c'est vrai c'est
complètement des magot Delphine et
encore une fois pourquoi est-ce qu'on
donne pas ces smartphones à des
travailleurs qui arrivent pas à boucler
leur fin de mois ou à des SDF qui sont
dans nos rues là n'empêche pas l'autre
on n'est pas d' pososer la misère oui
bah déjà c'est 500 smartphones je pense
qu'on peut déjà aider des gens qui sont
vraiment dans le besoin et qui se lèvent
malgré tout tous les matins en France là
en l'occurrence on dit que c'est aussi
beaucoup pour les femmes isolées avec
enfants euh c'est ce que dit
l'association et notamment pour les
aider dans dans un centre qui s'appelle
refugees women Center pour les soins
médicaux-sociaux pour le suivi des soins
médicaux-sciaux et c'est pour pouvoir de
pas qu'ell soi pas dans la nature quand
on a besoin de les suivre là-dessus
g et ça a fait travailler des gens cyil
c'est pour ça que j'aime bien il a fallu
recycler les téléphones et on les donne
à des gens démunis je trouve que c'est à
la fois humanitaire et utile parce que
des gens qui ont un téléphone on peut
les localiser on sait où ils sont ils
sont pas perdus et donc on peut les
sortir de cette situation difficile
voilà c'est pas parce que tu lui as
donné un téléphone que tu vas le
localiser s'il a pas envie de s'il a
envie de faire des trucs pas bien il
fera des trucs pas bien même avec ou
sans téléphone moi ça me dérange pas
qu'on don
oation unuc l'argent Dér pas qu' le
donne des téléph qui me Dér c'est qu'il
y a des G qui ont besoin de téléphone et
eux on les laisse sans téléphone c'est
toujours les deux POS de mesure on va
aider des gens n'importe comment dans
tous les sens et les gens qui
travaillent on les aide pas les
associations ça j'ai oui c'est pour ça
mais on aurait voulu aussi que cette
association là qu'ils vont dire les gens
sur l'association ils vont dire moi je
donne plus à cette association je dire
allez voir le sondage juste voir vous
allez voir le sondage regardez on va
réagir après regardez ce que pensent nos
téléspectateurs 91 % de nos
téléspectateurs sont choqués par ces 500
smartphones offerts à des migrant à calé
il y a beaucoup de choses qui reviennent
comme vient de dire Delphine est-ce que
quelqu'un comprend que les gens soient
choqués ou pas du y en a un qui compr
compr là sur le plateau c'est tout le
contraire alors où vous êtes trèsm dites
pas ce que vous pensez non non mais on
VO bien ici à 90 % ou vous dites pas ce
que vous pensez et vous êtes des Magos
ou bien le sondage est bizarre alors non
non on pense on pense exactement comme
les gens on se on se dit tous on se dit
ok c'est très bien qu'il a des téléphone
c'est pas l'argent public c'est une
association qui a fait ça mais en
contrepartie les gens qui sont chez eux
dit-mi moi j'ai une carte prépayée je
peux pas téléphoner moi je veux changer
mon téléphone mais j'en ai pas lui il se
retrouve avec un téléphone tout neuf je
lui pas demandé de venir là il y a plein
de gens qui qui vont tout mélanger je ve
dire il est venu on l'accueille en plus
faut une téléphone alors pourquoi on lui
pourquoi on lui offre pas un cabriolet
pourquoi on lui offre pas des sous pour
aller au restaurant pour pendant que moi
je vais bosser et que j'arrive pas à
boucler les fin de mois c'est ça les
gens ce qu' se disent fois on le message
est mauvais en fait on noffre pas des
téléphones comme ça ça changera pas sa
vie venez on essaie de de le faire venir
bien qui s'installe correctement on
essaie de lui trouver une insertion
peut-être du boulot mais les téphon
après après moi moi je vais me faire le
l'avocat aussi de l'association
l'association alors dans ce cas-là euh
on on on on critique ceux qui aident la
dernière fois ils avaient critiqué aussi
Bernard AR les les infoui parce qu'il
avait donné 10 millions d'euros au resto
du cœur on critique ceux qui font rien
et on critique ceux qui font donc à un
moment c'est vrai que c'est compliqué de
trouver le le le la la la la bonne euh
non non mais voilà de trouver le le bon
curseur parce que l'association elle
s'est dit je vais aider gens et voilà
l'association elle faitelle elle fait ce
qu'elle veut à la mais on critique pas
ce le fait qu'il le fasse ou on critique
que aujourd'hui en France il y a une
précarité qui est trop grande il y a des
gens qui sont vraiment sous ce sous ce
plafond de verre et aujourd'hui on sait
qu'un téléphone ça coûte très très cher
donc ces gens-là ces travailleurs
pauvres je préfère qu'il économise pour
pouvoir manger ce prix du téléphone et
que il soit un peu plus confortable tout
le mois durant plutôt que de le donner à
des migrants qui en plus de ça viennent
un peu de manière illégale en France
alors Gill tu es d'accord avecfine non
je suis pas d'accord parce que je je
comprends que les gens soient choqués
mais à mon avis ils sont choqués pour de
mauvaises raisons parce qu'il faut ilut
non non non non mais bah pourquoi non
mais je comprends que les gens soi
choqué pour c'est quoi
les que parce que en fait c'est des
téléphones qui sont reconditionnés ok
ils sont vendus 7 € le téléphone et donc
après il y a un pour 10 ou pour 100 qui
sont donnés à ces gensl ça fait partie
si vous voulez de ce qu'on appelle
l'économie circulaire donc c'est pour ça
que pour moi c'est pas choquant c'est
pas au détriment d'autres gens puisqu'il
y a plein de gens qui pour 70 € des
milliers 28000 déjà je crois auront un
téléphone oui mais là il est gratuitah
oui là il est gratuit oui donc 70 €
c'est pas rien qu'est-ce que tu racontes
mais 70 € sa ce que c'est 70 € mais
qu'est-ce qu' raconte 70 € c'est énorme
quoi aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il y a des
Français qui peuvent pas mettre 70 € je
désolé non mais qu'est-ce non mais tu
parles de 70 € on dirait que tu dis
c'est c'est c'est c'est un B je suis pas
d'accord 70 € c'est énorme es fou quoi
non mais je te le dis 70 € c'est
énormeentends parfait 70 € c'est un
abonnement tu sais les gens aujourd'hui
il peuvent pas sortir il pas faire de
loisir 70 € c'est presque un abonnement
voilà à Canal toute l'annéeà exactement
donc voilà parce que les gens peuvent
pas sortir donc forcément les loisirs
c'est chez eux aussi donc 70 balles tu
faut quoi c'est énorme donc ne dis pas
que les téléphones ils sont donnés 70 €
c'est pas donné mais oui mais c'est pas
t ton raisement ton raisonnement il est
faux excuse-moi parce que 70 € est
gratuit c'est pas pareil par rapport au
prix d'achat d'un téléphone neu 70 €
c'est desjà entre 70 € et la gratuité ça
n rien à voir non mais je te le dis
excuse-moi voilà donc j'entends ce que
vous dites mais Jean-Michel bah oui puis
en plus à partir je pense qu'ils s'en
serviront pas des téléphones parce qu'il
y a pas d'utilité à par tuas pas
d'opérateur ni rien donc ça va obet de
trafic V les revendre a des cartes
prépayéay payayut l'association
tu dans leur communiqué il disent que
les téléphones ça va servir par exemple
s'il tombe en pleine mer d'un zodiaque
pour appeler les secours il y a pas de
réseau en pleine mer toute façon ça sert
absolument rien ou s'il tombe du camion
pour appeler les secours c'est je la
communication est vraiment bancale je
sais pas je non mais après après moi moi
aussi il y a des gens s'ils avaient rien
fait on aurait dit ils font jamais rien
non mais on peut faire un standard
téléphoniqueù tout le monde peut venir
téléphoner gratuitement il distrib des
téléphones à tout le monde mais si on
fait de l'idéologie on trouve ça bien et
si on fait de la politique je comprends
comme comme Delphine qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui en France on est très tendu
par rapport à ces sujets on est
totalement sur la préférence nationale
il y a eu plein de fait divers sans sans
être dans une généralité immonde avec
malgré tout des migrants avec des
histoires de vol de viol de de de drogue
et tout ça donc effectivement je je peux
comprendre mais malgré tout je trouve
que c'est quand même une belle
initiative à partir du moment où c'est
une association voilà parce que de la
même manière à ce moment-là est-ce qu'on
peut pas enfin tu veux pas qu'on les
nourrisse tu veux pas qu'on leur donne
des vêtements tu vois parce que malgré
tout on les nourrit on leur donne des
vêtements on le donne des tentes non
mais d'accord non mais nourrir c'est il
y a des Français qui sont aussi dans la
rue et
qui Deline nourir c'estoin primaire tu
laisses pas des gens crever de faim
s'ils sont sur ton sol en revanche leur
donner un smartphone je suis désolé un
smartphone sera bien on leur donne pas
un Nokia ou quoi que soit on leur donne
un smartphone et ben ça je pense qu'on
peut le donner à des gens aujourd'hui
qui sont dans le besoinut font les deux
peut font les de mais c'est pas 70
€ 70 € voilà pour les autres g c'est 70
€ c'est ça après je voudrais aller dans
votre sens par rapport au sondage quand
même pas dans mon sens s'il te plaît
mais c'est vrai que je comprends aussi
parfaitement les gens de calis de grand
ines qui sont confrontés à une migration
qui n'est pas contrôlée ils en ont marre
dans leur vie quotidienne donc je pense
que quand ils disent qu'ils sont choqués
c'est aussi choqué de donner des gens
des téléphones à des gens qui ne
devraient pas être là et qui c'est vrai
causeent des problèmes dans la vie
quotidienne VO al c'est incroyable parce
que la semaine dernière Gill moi j'ai
dit que ça faisait peut-être baisser le
le prix le prix de l'immobilier des
choses comme ça quand il y avait des
migrants qui étai là et que ça faisait
peut-être un peu brouillon dans le
quartier cé unu compqué et là même ch on
parlait d'un hôtel c'est la même chose
moi j'ai dit que les gens quand ils sort
de tu dit exactement ce qu'elle a dit
Delphine la semaine dernière mais sauf
que l'année dernière semain dernière là
ça calé donc c'est quoi c'est la ville
qui change non je dis je comprends que
les gens soient choqués dans le sondage
non mais tu dis exactement ce qu'elle a
dit mais comme les gens à calé bah oui
tu dis exact redislui ce que tu as dit
la semaine dernière on va voir s'il va
comprendre la semaine dernière j'ai dit
que s'il y a des migrants dans un hôtel
et qu'on dégage les clients officiels et
qu'on met les migrants bah au bout d'un
moment ça va aussi gêner les riverins
qui sont dans dans cette villeel ça
peut-être faire baisser le le le le le
la valeur le prix de l'immobilier merci
et tout ça et il me semble que toi tu
mtais un peu tombé dessus en disant oh
là là mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
dire ça même
chose c'est vrai Ren voir il fait ça on
avait d'ailleurs passé un reportage où
les Riverin exprimaiit leur
frustration j'analyse ce que pense
j'essaie de d'analyser ce que pensent
les gens je donne pas mon opinion à moi
simplement que comprend les gens dans
leur vie quotidienne c'est très
difficile alors maintenant toi
maintenant tu es devenu sociologue en
fait donc en fait
j'essaie de me mettre au niveau de
Delphine et c'est pas toujours facile
jeux c'est vrai qu'à mon avis
elle c'est vrai qu'elle a un niveau
tellement haut par rapport à toi que ça
doit être difficile
allez j'adore Gill verd sauf dans les
débats vous le savez puis en plus pour
on pourrait qu'est-ce que tuas toi
[Applaudissements]
encore on pourit peut-être aider en
priorité les migants qui veulent
s'installer en France travaill en France
plutôt que ceux qui n'ontcune envie
c'est de se barrer de France pour en
angleterret sélectionné ces migrants ils
sontés ils ontune envie c'est de partir
en Angleterre donc on est des gens qui
veulent qui veulent pas rester en France
en plus ce son et donc ceux qui restent
en France ce sont des personnes
vulnérables tuas pas travailler le
dosser laisse tomber pas travailler
bosse un peu tu reviendras excuse-moi
mais toi tu as travaillé un dossier ce
soir regarde devant toi tu as pas une
fiche tu sais même pas ce qu' le
conducteur alorsant
faut qu'est-ce qu'il y
aah bien sûr dei on va parler io on va
parler ce soirah les
[Applaudissements]
valangoriaor Pascal la tour du pain
qu'est-ce que tu penses de tout ça de
quoi
des Valoria
je ris de faire sa connaissance moi
j'étais fan de despr House wives donc
comme beaucoup c'est ça la
question non mais il y a que des fux
ramenez-moi ces
collègues